[Music]  20 years ago  we got our first glimpse  into the wizarding world you're a wizard  harry i'm a what and the spell was cast  [Music]  [Music]  i want to be a wizard  it's a world that enchants the ordinary  [Music]  charms our senses  and unlocks our imagination  i think we can expect great things from  you  it's a chance to spend time with friends  we know  and be introduced to those we've not yet  met  whether it's on a page  on a stage  or on a screen  it's all part of one world  it inspired our own  [Music]  every great wizard in history has  started out  as nothing more than what we are now  if they can do it why not us  and new adventures are on the horizon  the world as we know it is coming undone  things that seem unimaginable today  will seem inevitable tomorrow  should you agree to do what i ask you'll  have to trust me  even when every instinct tells you not  [Music]  you